hello i would like to start by thanking
the organizers
of the conference for letting me present
this work it is called towards local
testability for quantum coding
my name is vivian lund and this is joint
work with anthony leverie
from indriya and jill zemor from the
bordeaux mathematical institute
so in this talk i'm going to use two
different kinds of vocabulary
on the one hand the vocabulary of
quantum codes ldpc quantum codes
and on the other hand the vocabulary of
local hamiltonians
and these two notions are equivalent so
i'll give right away the correspondence
and give more details later on
a local hamiltonian whose ground space
is degenerate
that is it can contains more than
once one state it corresponds to quantum
code
that has a non-trivial code space so
a code a quantum code that encodes more
than one state
and in terms of ldpc quantum codes
we will talk about the weight
of the syndrome of an error and in terms
of hamiltonians we will talk about the
energy
of this error but these two terms are
also the same
and what we will focus on in this talk
is
local locally testable codes so that
means that
the weight of the syndrome scales
linearly
with the size of the er or in other
words that the energy of this air
scales linearly with its size
so let me take a step back and give them
the current status on consumer
correction
actually most of the research is not
focused on
locally testable codes it's more focused
on
building a large quantum computer and
using some practical quantum codes
to do this and for a code to be
practical
it's better if it has some
physical locality and so that's why most
of the research is
concerned with 2d and 3d euclidean codes
because this way the physical qubits can
be
arranged locally with the same
constraint
as the definition of the code itself and
it makes
building such a such a
quantum code much easier for
experimentalists
so with these constraints um the the
codes that
the quantum codes that can be built are
surface codes or 3d variants
and this is a very very promising
approach it's
it works quite well it was it works very
well
because these codes have high thresholds
and
there are some efficient decoders
that are known for these codes
and on top of this it's it's possible to
implement fault tolerance schemes with
the
with such codes even though the overhead
is quite large
it's it's not so bad
so so all these good news
may give the impression that the
research on
quantum era correction is more or less
done
so why do we why do we care actually
about quantum locally testable codes and
such other properties
well even before i introduce
um local testability even in terms of
nk and d the standard parameters of a
code and a quantum code the the con the
2d and 3d constraints
are quite restrictive and the parameters
that
we can reach so there are some
upper bounds on what is doable in terms
of
the number of physical qubits n the
number of logical qubits k
or dimension of the code and the
distance
the minimum distance d of this code
the the most
restrictive of these upper bounds
is the one given by sergey pravi david
pooler and barbara terrell in 2010.
if we impose that the code is
two-dimensional and euclidean
then the product of k and and the
squared of the minimum distance
cannot be larger than a constant times
the length of the code
it's number of physical qubits um
so this bound is is very restrictive and
it's
actually reached by the tory code and
all the the surface code
the family of surface codes if we allow
some geometry that is a bit more
exotic like hyperbolic geometry
but we still restrict our attention on
2d codes
it's possible to do a little better it's
possible actually to
to win a logarithmic factor
and this is um but not more
and this is shown but by the the
bound from nicola del foss in 2014
which tells you that the product of k
and d squared
is not uh larger than log k
squared times uh and the number of
qubits
but if if we don't impose this
two two-dimensional restriction we can
do
even better and this was shown first by
guth and lubotsky in 2014
that all the bounds above can be
broken by such construction so
even in terms of nknd it makes sense to
ask what can we get
what improvements are possible when we
keep the
ldpc constraints but allow for more
exotic
locality more exotic geometry
than than 2d or yeah then 2d euclidean
ones or 2d hyperbolic ones
so let me now take uh another step back
and um talk very briefly about classical
codes
these codes are very well understood and
um there are some construction for
instance random constructions
that give a dimension k
and a minimum distance d that are both
linear in the length
of the classical error correcting code
and there are
also some some very efficient decoding
algorithms that are known
such as belief propagation for instance
but uh in contrast to
classical codes quantum ldpc codes
are not so well are really poorly
understood
um so let me first define what i mean by
quad
quantum ldpc code um
so a quantum code is is defined by a set
of generators
um and the constraint on
these generators is that the they must
commute uh two by two pairwise
and um so that's that's the definition
of a quantum code
and the codes space associated with it
is the
vector space
of the vectors the vector space of
states
that are fixed by all these generators
all these poly operators and now the
ldpc
condition ldpc meaning low density
priority check
means that each of these generators
must act like the identity on all qubits
except a constant or a logarithmic
number of them and that's the first
constraint
and it corresponds to having a parity
check matrix
whose rows have constant or logarithmic
weight but there is another one
corresponding to the fact that the
columns
of the parity check matrices have
constant or logarithmic weight
and in words it means that
each qubit is acted on by a non-identity
generator only a constant or logarithmic
number of time
and with this definition there is still
a notion of
locality given by ldbc
but it's way less restrictive than what
we had before with the
2d or 3d constructions so the question
is open
what kind of nkmd parameters can be
reached is it possible to have
efficient decoders for such codes
and and what we're going to focus on
in this talk particularly is which
property
of a quantum code makes it easy to
decode
and we will see that local testability
is is such a property
about the decoding for 2d and 3d
topological codes
it's essentially solved but
meaning that there are some good
decoders that are both
efficient and also close to the
performances of
maximum likelihood decoders but
for general codes it's um
it's much more open then
there are some well it's it makes sense
to
try the belief propagation decoder since
it's it's a decoder that works well well
with classical codes
but in the quantum setting it doesn't
work so well because of the
small cycles that quantum codes always
have
and then it's possible it's quite uh
it happens quite often that the the
bullet propagation decoder gets
uh stuck and
yeah build propagation doesn't work so
well with general codes
for for
4d codes and for other for quantum
expander codes
as well um there are some greedy
decoders
that works well but
it would be interesting to to have a
more general decoder
and to understand why these decoders
work well
and actually for quantum expander codes
um
[Music]
part of the answer is given by uh
the soundness of codes so i haven't
defined soundness yet
it's it's actually a
a notion very close to local testability
so the soundness of the code uh well the
soundness of an
error to start with is
a constant such that the syndrome of
this air
is greater than this constant ital
times the weight of the error and the
standards of the code
is the minimal soundness for all the
all the errors all possible errors so
if a code has good soundness meaning
that
it is constant with respect to a code
family
then it is easy to distinguish between
words that are far from the code and
in words that are in words that
belong to the to the code space
only by looking at a constant number of
checks
or by looking at a constant number of
qubits in other words
and this notion in the classical
settings
has many applications uh for instance
um it played a crucial role in the proof
of the
pcp theorem
um what about quantum locality stable
codes
so this notion was introduced in 2015
and there are a few results about it
but the main applications are still a
bit unclear
though the question some questions lots
of questions are still open
and a first result is that if
there were if if there is a code
that is both quantum locally testable
and has linear minimum distance
then this would give the this would
establish the nltc conjecture
but this is a very strong requirement
because
even without talking about quantum
locality stable codes
we don't know yet any quantum code any
ldpc quantum code that has linear
minimum distance
so a requirement that is a bit
less strong is to only ask
um for quantum locality stability
without linear minimum distance
and this is the subject of this talk
and this gives a weaker version of nltc
which is only the
average case nltc and
on another line of research it is also
known that
locality stability has
some strong links with single-shot
decoding
and this was explained by
earl campbell in 2018
so so these are application of quantum
locally
testable codes but let me give the
definition now
the idea is to start from the definition
of classical
locality stability and to quantize it
so first let me give a formal
translation between a quantum code
and the local hamiltonian associated to
it
and the trick is to take all the
stabilizers
of the quantum code and to
define a term of the local hamiltonians
as one half of the identity minus the
stabilizers
and you can see that if you take a state
that is fixed
by such a stabilizer it corresponds to
an eigenstate of this part of the
hamiltonian with eigenvalue 0
and a state that is
that takes a that gets a phase of -1
with respect to gi with respect to the
stabilizers
will corresponds to an eigenvalue
an eigenvector with eigenvalue 1 for
this term of the hamiltonian
and since all the stabilizers of the
quantum code are required to commute
with each other
all these terms of the hamiltonian
commute as well
and it's possible to find a common basis
of diagonalization
of this local hamiltonian and this is
why
this is how you can see that the weight
of the syndrome
of an um of an eigen
of an operator of the quantum code
corresponds to
the energy of the eigenvector
defined as a state of the code space
on which you act by the operator
corresponding to this error
so so it's possible to with this
definition to go back and forth between
quantum codes and local hamiltonian now
to define the distance to the code in
terms of hamiltonian
it's possible uh if we introduce
ct which is the
vector space spanned by all the
um states of the codespace on which
you act by operators that are tensor
products
such that only a constant number of them
or a logarithmic number of them
are not the identity and if you define
projectors
on such spaces ct and take the
difference
between the projector on ct and the
projector on c
t minus one you actually get a projector
on the states that are at distance
exactly t
from the code space and if you
give the weight t to two such states
it's possible to construct this where
the the distance operator
that is denoted dc here and we say that
the the quantum code is locally testable
if the the operator hc
is greater than a constant time
the operator distance dc so that means
that the the difference of the two
operator is a
is a positive operator um
so so it is a generalization a
quantization of the
of the classical notion of local
testability
so what is known um about this notion
well there is a construction from 2017
from matthew hastings that gives
a soundness which is almost constant
it's one over log
cube of the length of the code and it
encodes
two logical qubits and in this works we
get a soundness which is a little better
it's a little smaller
it's um it's only one over
sorry it's a little larger it's only one
over
log squared of the length of the quantum
code but it encodes only one logical
qubit
and we have a conjecture that it's
possible to to also have a sun nest that
is one over
polylog with with a number of logical
qubits which is a great written one
which is uh greater than which is
non-constant sorry
so um to understand what locally
testable codes are
it's actually easier to picture some
codes
some quantum codes that are not locally
testable
and the most famous of them are not
for instance all the 2d codes like 2d
story codes if you take a chain
of errors that are all on the that are
on
edges of the toy code that are all
incidents that are pairwise incident to
each other
you will get a syndrome of weight only
two
and it's possible to do this for errors
of weights
there are of order square roots of n
square root of the
length of the code and and this shows
that
such codes are are not locally disabled
because to be locally testable you would
need to have a syndrome weight
that is linear in the size of the error
and for d-dimensional codes
d-dimensional theory codes the situation
is a little better
but it's also not locally testable to
see this you can think
of a four-dimensional three code for
instance where qubits are identified
with the two faces with packets
and if you think of an error that is
made of
of all this all the the two faces
in a big square well the number of
qubits
will be l squared where
l is the is the length of a side of the
square
and the perimeter of this square is
going to be 4l
so so you can see that the weight of the
syndrome is actually square root
of the weight of the air itself so it's
it's too small
to be locally testable and finally if
you
consider quantum expander codes as
i said before they have some they
satisfy
the locality stability inequality but
only for errors
that are smaller that have the weights
more than
square root of the length of the code so
for some errors
that that have weight of the order of
the square root of the length of the
code
um you will have a constant energy
and that that shows that quantum
expander codes are none
are not locally testable codes
so now i will give the the construction
of the hemi cubic code the one that
gives the
this good local disability and let me
mention that this construction
was previously called the projective
code in a previous conference
so um such codes
give you the following nkd parameters k
is always equal to one but the minimum
distance
grows like the square root of the
number of physical qubits so this is
similar to
what you have for surface codes
but the big difference is that um you do
have a good soundness namely 1
over log squared of the number of
physical qubits
and we also have a generalization that
encodes a polynomial number of logical
qubits
and still has a minimum distance which
is polynomial
in the number of physical qubits but for
this generalization
the local physics testability is only
conjectured
so what's the idea between
behind the construction it's it starts
with a
well-known fact about two-dimensional
codes
namely a connection between the geometry
of two-dimensional surfaces and the
minimum distance
of codes built from tessellations of
such
surfaces the number of physical qubits
will be
proportional to the area of such a
surface
and the minimum distance will be
proportional to the
shortest closed loop on such a surface
um so with this intuition in mind if we
want to maximize the minimum distance
at a fixed um
at a fixed area it's the same as
minimizing
the area at the fixed system at a fixed
minimum distance
so it makes sense to do this to consider
some surface with a positive curvature
because the the discs
in the surface with positive curators
have an
area which is smaller for a given radius
of such a disc so it's a good
direction to look into and and indeed
if we consider the real projective plane
so what's a real projective plane it's
it's a sphere such that antipodal points
are identified
well such such a 2d surface
has a systel equal to pi if we consider
a sphere with a radius one but its
area is only two pi so
it shows that the the systole in this
case is greater than the square root of
the area
and this would be a hint that the
minimum distance would be greater than
square root of n
but it's not possible to construct an
infinite family of quantum codes
with this construction so we'll need to
do something else then
only real projective plane will consider
real projective
spaces in them in dimension more than
two
and this is similar to construction by
hastings in 2016
where here we considered high
dimensional manifolds
so instead of doing it in a geometric
setting we will directly go to a
discrete setting
and take cubes this way
we have an easy discretization
of of the geometry and to turn
so cube is is topologically uh like a
sphere if you take the
the the outer surface of this cube and
to make it
uh have the same topology as a
projective plane
we will identify opposite antipodal
edges
and typical vertices and antipotential
two phases
and by doing so we get a quantum code
that has one minimum distance equal to
three
as you can see the the loop in red
has length six but since opposites edges
are identified
it actually has lens three and
the other minimum distance is two
um the one where you take
um co boundaries of edges and
it's interesting to note that the
products of these two minimum distances
is equal to the number of physical
qubits
of this construction and indeed this
generalizes to hypercubes of dimension
more than three if you identify qubits
with p
faces for any p between one and n minus
one
you will um it's it's possible to
compute the minimum distances
of such a code and uh it will always
hold
that the number of physical qubits is
the product of the two minimum distances
so it's not possible to to break the
square root of n barrier with such a
construction but it's possible to reach
it
at least um
and um in terms of local testability
well we have to normalize
well since since the hemi cubic code
has weights check weights
that is logarithmic in the number of
physical qubits
we have to take this into account and
normalize the soundness
the constant of the locality stability
and we can prove that we will get a
soundness which is 1 over log
squared of the number of physical qubits
so since
the constant of the soundness is
the constant between a syndrome that is
a boundary
and the air corresponding to this
syndrome that is a feeling of this
boundary
what we are looking at for the hypercube
is
filling inequalities and luckily
um this is a subject that has already
been looked at
notably by doterra in 2012
and he noted that it's possible to find
filling inequalities of um
of of small
where the filling has a small weight
compared to the size of the boundary
and it's actually an algorith an
algorithmic
proof a constructive proof where the
feeling is given
by fixing a direction and
and sending this way all the syndrome
to one side of the hypercube
and then iterating by choosing other
directions of the hypercube
and by doing that as you can see
on the on the drawing on the right it's
possible to
have a boundary or have a feeling
of size no more than constant times
its syndrome its boundary so this is for
the hypercube
which corresponds which has no homology
and
therefore corresponds to a quantum code
with um only one state
like the codespaces is only the
made of one state so it's not
interesting
uh like this but it's possible to adapt
it to the case
of the hemi cube that does have a
logical qubit
and in the adaptation adaptation we lose
we lose a logarithmic factor but that's
how we get
the this soundless inequality and
almost local stability of hemi cubic
codes
so to to generalize this construction
we can observe that taking
that ident identifying antipodal
edges vertices and faces is the same as
taking the quotient
by the repetition code and so the
generalization
comes from taking the questions by
another classical code not not the
repetition code but
any other classical code
and and this works well
um so so once we make this
identification the
the the improvement we get is that the
number of logical qubits
encoded in such a code is
much greater it's much more than one and
we can prove that it's
p p plus k minus 1 choose p
where p is the dimension where we put
the qubits
and k is the dimension of the classical
code we
take the question by and it's surprising
that this number the number of logical
qubits
doesn't depend on uh the details of the
classical codes
but only on its dimension and the
dimension p where we put
the physical qubits
so um to summarize
and to give some perspectives we have
given two constructions of quantum codes
the simple version is the hemi cube
you can it's also the the n-dimensional
cube with the
anti-portal faces identified and this
gives the minimum distance which is
square root of the number of physical
qubits and a code that is
locally testable and we also gave a more
general version
where the n-cube is we take
its quotient by any
linear classical code and we're able to
prove the dimension and the minimum
distance in this case
but we could only conjecture and not
prove that this generalization
also gives locality stable quantum codes
so
we this leaves many open questions
uh many questions still open
for instance um what is the length so
the
the the best k possible um sorry what is
the best n possible for
quantum location codes what is its
relationship with respect to
its dimension is it exponential
polynomial
this is food for future work
so i'd like to thank you for your
attention and if you have
any questions or would like some
precision don't hesitate to contact
myself
or my co-authors antonido variety and
jill zimmer
thank you bye